bonsoir et bienvenue en direct sur
france 3 normandie pour vivre ensemble
ce second tour des élections régionales
dans notre région nous y sommes la
normandie devrait connaître ce soir son
futur et unique président de région et
pour vivre cette soirée historique
france 3 et bien sûr se mobilisent pour
recueillir tous les résultats les
analyses et les commentaires de nous
inviter ici en plateau mais aussi depuis
les cinq départements normands bonsoir
france
bonsoir ml effectivement trois heures de
direct pour suivre l'évolution de ce
scrutin et le suspense est entier on va
voir le résultat d'une étude ipsos
estimation ipsos pour france 3 normandie
les deux listes de la droite et de
l'union de la gauche sont parfaitement à
égalité à l'heure à laquelle nous
parlons
regardez 36 3%
pour hervé morin 36 3 % pour nicolas
mayer rossignol le front national c'est
ce soir une certitude ne gagnera pas la
normandie puisqu'il arrive en troisième
position avec 27,4 pour cent ça n'est
qu'une estimation on attend les
résultats officiels
mais si la plus grande incertitude ce
soir sur l'issue du scrutin
voilà le suspense donc se prolonge alors
avant de partir évidemment à recueillir
quelques réactions de nos invités et des
candidats de second tour on va analyser
un autre chiffre aussi important ce soir
celui de la participation 58,9 au second
tour une participation nettement en
hausse par rapport au premier tour de
dimanche dernier en normandie 48,9 ses
neuf points de plus qu'au premier tour
est ce que l'on peut dire philippe goudé
justement qu'un quand on a plus profité
qu'un autre est ce qu'on peut déjà aller
jusque là
sans aller jusque-là déjà soulignons les
non républicain qu'on l'a connue lors de
ce deuxième tour on avait été satisfait
des quatre points de plus la semaine
dernière par rapport au premier tour de
2010 c'était pas mal mais c'était loin
quand même d'atteindre des sommets
là on revient
en normandie en tout cas en haute
normandie je suis pas pour la
basse-normandie haute-normandie aux
chiffres on l'avait connu en 1998 qui
est tout à fait correct de participation
élevé diablement oui il ya eu un sursaut
républicain
alors pour répondre plus précisément à
votre question on en saura un peu plus
tout à l'heure aux regardant notamment
dans les grandes villes
c'est là qu'on peut faire sur un étiage
relativement important de votants des
calculer les comparaisons pour savoir un
petit peu à qui justement ce sursaut
républicain profiter a priori je vous
rappelle quand même les données du
problème
la semaine dernière les le total des
voix de gauche était nettement supérieur
à celui de la droite
là on est à égalité parfaite pour le
moment le front national n'a pas
vraiment perdu mais n'a pas vraiment
gagné non plus donc de ce côté là
verront sans doute et il n'y avait pas
de réserve de voix
donc a priori on pourrait supposer que
c'est plutôt à droite que les gens se
sont mobilisés mais attendons d'en
savoir plus il y avait aussi une autre
problématique pour la gauche
c'était de savoir si les reports de voix
allaient correctement s'afficher
rappelle quand même que la constitution
de la liste a mis un petit peu de temps
la liste d'union avant le deuxième tour
et puis que pour le programme
bon c'était pas hyper précis on leur
accordera les cours de la soirée alors
ce suspense forcément on n'en doute pas
il va forcément inspiré chaunu qui
passera à cette soirée avec nous bonsoir
chaunu exceptionnel mais je vais
d'exceptionnels comme soirée pour un
caricaturiste c'est merveilleux du
caviar du caviar et nous allons
également surveiller tout ce qui se
passe sur internet notre équipe web et
au travail où on retrouvera emilie qui
est se trouve c'est aurélie oui tous les
échos il ya tellement des milices et
c'est bien pour les échos sur la sur la
toile
à tout à l'heure ce résultat qui vient
de nous parvenir également tiens qui
peut être intéressant dans le
département de l'eure celui de guy
lefranc qui interviendra dans quelques
instants
98% des bulletins ont été dépouillés et
c'est la liste d'hervé morin qui arrive
en tête alors que leur avait placé en
première position dimanche dernier le
front national cette fois donc c'est
hervé morin avec 36 0 8%
nicolas bay le front national 34 94 et
nicolas mayer rossignol en troisième
position avec 28,98 % nle
c'est sur résultats partiels 1 98% des
bureaux de vote
on va rappeler bien sûr franquin que
nous sommes présents dans les cinq
départements normands dans les
préfectures de rouen d'evreux de saint
lô de caen ou encore d'alençon bien sûr
on va recueillir une première action sur
ce plateau le suspense on le disait et
est entier catherine morin desailly vous
venez de nous rejoindre d'être
conseillère régionale sortante udi pour
la haute-normandie proche d'hervé morin
sénatrice également que vous inspire
justement ce suspense là entre les deux
lycées ce que vous attendiez justement
un score aussi serré les sondages
prévoyaient les sondages l'annoncent est
mon élément de satisfaction c'est que la
participation était beaucoup plus
importante que la semaine dernière
évidemment elle a profité à l'ensemble
des trois listes en présence peut-être
un peu plus à la liste que nous
représentons avec mon collègue guy
lefrand de l'heure mais reste à voir je
crois au fur et à mesure que les
résultats vont tomber
comment les résultats vont
définitivement s'orienter il est vrai
que le suspense est total et on a
rarement vécu un moment aussi intense
hélène mialon burgat justement pour le
ps quel est votre sentiment ce soir on
savait madame brand de ça ils disaient
que l'écart était infime
y croyez-vous encore oui ce serait
difficile de le dire vraiment il faut
attendre des résultats consolidés par le
par la préfecture
il ya tellement de peu d'écart qu
aujourd'hui à la à ce moment là je ne
peux rien dire comme un collègue
effectivement je peux me réjouir aussi
d'une meilleure participation est peu
partout dans les grandes villes et dans
l'est et dans les territoires donc ça
c'était un élément de satisfaction pour
tout le monde
on frôle les 60 % ce qui est vraiment
très très bien la mobilisation est forte
et tout à fait intéressante on va partir
si vous le voulez bien en préfecture de
rouen retrouver catherine leconte
bonsoir catherine avez vous plus
d'informations que nous par rapport à
ses estimations dites nous comment ça a
voté en seine-maritime si vous le savez
catherine alors ça a voté massivement on
vous l'avait dit tout à l'heure avec 54%
à peu près des voies le seul en tout cas
ce que tu veux vous dire maintenant
c'est que le suspense se course
aucune grande ville pour l'instant n'est
encore tombée les seuls résultats dont
nous disposons pour l'instant sont par
exemple ce d'elbeuf et bien nicolas
mayer rossignol sans surprise est
arrivée en tête avec 51 29 % des voix
juste devant donc messieurs nicolas bay
avec 28 points 76 % des voix hervé morin
avec 19% elbeuf qui avaient voté
massivement à près de 60 2%
donc pour l'instant on attend avec
impatience les résultats des grandes
villes on attendait aussi de nombreux
ténors qui devait nous rejoindre pour
l'instant personne n'est encore arrivé
ici preuve qu'il ya encore une certaine
fébrilité en tout cas dans les états
majors et que l'on compte sérieusement
les voies tout pourrait se jouer en fait
à quelques centaines de voix de voix
près donc ici en seine maritime comme
dans l'ensemble de la région en tout cas
le suspense est entier je rappelle cette
estimation donc de notre partenaire
ipsos eux avec ce score extrêmement
serré entre les deux principales listes
celle d'hervé morin pour l'union de la
droite et du centre et celle de nicolas
mayer rossignol 36 3% pour toutes les
deux le score national est en troisième
position selon ipsos avec 27,4 pour cent
on va aller à alençon retrouver nicolas
corbard avez-vous des résultats ou des
estimations pour le département de
l'eure nicolas franquin ce que je peux
vous donner pour le moment c'est une
tendance avec des résultats partiels
saisi à 92% pour le moment la droite
arriverait en tête avec un écart non
négligeable par rapport à la gauche qui
arrivera en seconde position donc et en
troisième position trouverait le front
national qui avoisinerait tout de même
les 30% mais il s'agit là je voulais
dire d'une tendance puisque les
résultats de certaines grandes villes ne
sont pas encore connues flers arles
alençon et l'aigle n'ont pas encore
communiqué leurs résultats je vous
rappelle qu'ici dans l'orne au premier
tour c'était le front national qui était
arrivée en tête avec 29 points 0 4% des
voix suivi par la droite d'hervé morin
avec 28 34% des suffrages et en
troisième position se trouvait à la
liste
pl mais cette socialiste qui recueillait
23 05 % des voix liste menée dans l'orne
par laurent beauvais le président
sortant du conseil régional de
basse-normandie et une liste de gauche
qui a évolué puisque au second tour à la
fusionner avec le front de gauche et
europe écologie à les verts ont donc on
trouve donc trois nouveaux candidats sur
cette liste un pour le front de gauche 2
pour europe ecologie les verts dont
yannick soubien l'ancienne tête de liste
régionale 1 pour les verts qui arrive en
troisième position sur cette liste
d'union de la gauche le fort taux de
participation qui est pour le moment 2
62% ses 11 points de plus qu'au premier
tour
va-t-il profiter donc à la droite à la
gauche ou en front national et bien on
va le savoir dans quelques instants
merci nicolas et les résultats nous
parviennent au fur et à mesure avranches
par exemple dans le sud du département
de la manche avec la liste d'hervé morin
qui arrive en tête avec 47 12% devant
celle de nicolas mayer rossignol 36,51
et le front national 16 37%
on va reparler d'avranches certainement
dans quelques instants on y lire on ira
à saint lô on va prendre pour le moment
la direction de caen où nous attend
guénaëlle louis avez-vous des résultats
définitifs des tendances des partiels
sur le calvados le guen n a pas encore
de résultats définitifs ici à la
préfecture du calvados voici des
résultats partiels qui représente 84 %
des inscrits prévu selon cette première
estimation
la liste d'union de la droite et du
centre menée par hervé morin arrive en
tête avec 39,2 24% des voix suivie de la
liste d'union de la gauche de nicolas
meyer rossignol 36 36% en troisième la
liste front national de nicolas bay
24,39 % alors attention je vous ai dit
ces résultats ne sont que partielles en
même temps les résultats de six communes
simplement sur les 700 cinq que compte
le calvados les plus grandes villes
d'ailleurs hérouville-saint-clair
lisieux bayeux ou encore vire qui avait
mis en tête au premier tour la liste
d'hervé morin il ya quelques surprises
on a eu les résultats définitifs de la
ville de caen la ville de caen qui avait
mis hervé morin en tête au premier tour
eh bien là c'est nicolas mayer rossignol
qui l'emporterait avec 46
50% des voix hervé morin obtiendrait
40,6 53% et la liste front national
12,97 quant au taux de participation
eh bien il s'élève à 61 % ces dix points
de plus par rapport au 2e tour des
régionales de 2010 merci beaucoup gainey
alors évidemment il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'incertitudes un forcément sur ce
second tour avec tout de même des
résultats définitifs qui nous arrivent
au compte-gouttes notamment pour le
département de l'eure avec hervé morin
qui arriveraient en tête devant nicolas
bay cette fois-ci et et nicolas mayer
rossignol en troisième position va
partir justement dans la préfecture
d'evreux retrouver frédéric nicolas
bonsoir frédéric qu'entendez vous quelle
est la tendance que vous avez vous du
côté d'evreux
bonsoir emilie bonsoir à tous alors pour
le moment effectivement c'est une
tendance n'avons pas encore eu les
résultats définitifs nous ici sur les
six cent soixante quinze communes du
département il ne manque que cinq
résultats louvier gisors evreux les
andelys et vernon mais une forte
tendance pour l'instant qui se dessine
c'est ce que disait franck besnier tout
à l'heure selon 97 8 % des communes
saisi hervé morin sera en tête avec 36%
des voix un petit peu plus de 36% des
voix suivi de nicolas bay près de 35% et
nicolas mayer rossignol près de 29% donc
le député centriste
elle serait en tête ici dans le
département de l'eure il a réalisé près
de 64% dans sa commune dépeignent
dépasser les 45 % ou avoisiner à
pacy-sur-eure berné ou encore le
neubourg
de son côté nicolas maillot rationne
mayer rossignol a réalisé près de 63% à
val de reuil où c'est marc antoine jamet
qui menait la liste 45% à pont de
l'arche et le score également de nicolas
bay près de 38% du côté d'aubevoye et
donc jouer à l'instant les résultats
vous avez eu avant moi et bien c'est
donc hervé morin qui serait donc en tête
avec 36 1% des voix ici dans leur suivi
de nicolas b 35% donc c'était à peu près
semblable à cette prévision qu'on vous
donner tout à l'heure et je vous ai
redonné en début d'intervention
merci beaucoup frédéric elle là vous
parlez de résultats définitifs alors que
nous sommes encore avec nos estimations
et bien qui bouge qui s'affine au fil de
la soirée
et un petit changement franck il
semblerait selon nos estimations ipsos
que nicolas mayer rossignol soit
finalement en tête avec 36 4% devant
hervé morin avec 36,2 % et nicolas bay
le front national 27,4 pour cent mais on
reste très très prudents l'écart est
vraiment minces et puis il ne s'agit que
d'estimations à la sortie des urnes
oui tout à fait et on va poser la
question justement à guy lefrand le
maire et les républicains d'evreux sa
safin un petit peu mais ça se joue à
quelques dizaines peut-être quelques
centaines de voix près 36 4 pour le
candidat socialiste en 6,2 pour le
candidat que vous soutenez hervé morin
est ce que vous croyez encore que cette
victoire cette victoire historique
puisque ce sera la première de la
normandie réunifiée est possible ce soir
oui la victoire est possible mais je
pense que comme l'ont dit les uns les
autres aujourd'hui nous restons à
l'heure qu'il est dans l'incertitude
nous sommes en attente
la seule chose c'est que nous avons
constaté un taux de participation
beaucoup plus important ce qui est pour
nous une vraie réussite
je constate que en valeur absolue renom
de voix le front national est stable ne
bouge pas ou quasiment pas et donc je
pense qu'il a il est aujourd'hui à son
maximum et qui a eu ce sursaut
républicain qui a permis à la fois à la
gauche et à la droite de remonter de
mobiliser ses électeurs
ça c'est une première satisfaction pour
le reste je crois que nous allons voir
et surtout nous aurons à rester très
humble quel que soit le vainqueur ce
soir parce que nous allons avoir à
décortiquer ces résultats expliqué
pourquoi notamment dans le monde rural
nous avons autant d'électeurs qui ont
choisi de faire confiance au front
national
yannick soubien vous étiez tête de liste
pour europe écologie et les verts au
premier tour vous avez fait la fusion
avec la liste du parti socialiste avec
le prg et le front de gauche c'est très
très très serré effectivement ça se joue
à quelques voix près ce soit l'euro fort
c'était quand même très favorables
à la gauche on était sûrs du 39 33 à
l'issue du premier tour
comment expliquer justement que ce soit
aussi indécis mais côté il ya déjà
quelque chose qui moi me paraît
important c'est qu'on était tous un peu
inquiet on parlait tous d'urgence
démocratique au premier tour en disant
il ya un taux d'abstention important moi
je crois qu'il faut quand même qu'on
considère que ça c'est une vraie
évolution et je constate que c'est
effectivement dans toutes les familles
politiques de choses les choses ce sont
les gens se sont mobilisés
donc ça c'est un point important le
deuxième point c'est pas moi j'ai envie
de vous dire quand même au plan national
une aucune région ne sera gouverné par
le front national c'est une bonne
nouvelle
deuxième chose hier soir il s'est passé
quelque chose d'important l'aco 21 nous
avions parlé de l'urgence écologique
tous les pays du monde se sont mobilisés
pour faire en sorte que et l'urgence
démocratique et l'urgence écologique
soit prise en compte c'est déjà une
bonne nouvelle
on verra tout à l'heure effectivement
c'est très serré c'est historique ça
fait partie du jeu démocratique
alors on va se rendre à caen dans cette
grande normandie qui est en construction
avec nous en duplex depuis la préfecture
du calvados
le maire les républicains de la ville
joseph bruno au bon soir joël bruneau
les électeurs car et ont placé en tête
la liste d'hervé morin ce n'est pas
vraiment une surprise avec plus de 40%
d'entre vous est cher ami
non non celle inverse comme le comme
prévu et comme logiquement sur la foi du
premier tour c'est la liste de gauche
qui est en tête mais moins que prévu et
on le doit à la mobilisation des
électeurs de la droite et du centre qui
effectivement on était au rendez vous de
ce second tour
vous êtes en fait en tête sur l'ensemble
du département du calvados a été lancée
sur le son la ville de caen mais quelle
est votre réaction ce soir justement ma
réaction c'est que comme tout le monde
on attend avec impatience les résultats
définitifs c'est extrêmement serré ce
qui n'était pas acquis d'avancé parce
que si on faisait un strict report de
voix il est très très clair que la
gauche était légèrement en tête
enfin papa de l'enfant en tout cas de
plusieurs milliers de voix sur la à
l'échelle de la normandie là on serait
dans un mouchoir de poche
ce qui veut dire encore une fois qu'il
ya une vraie mobilisation des électeurs
de la droite et du centre et que
c'est bien ma foi je suis comme vous
j'attends est ce que vous dites
simplement ce soir que caen doit jouer
un rôle privilégié capital tiré dans
cette grande normandie
en deux mots moi je dis ce soir ce que
je non je dis ce soir ce que j'ai
toujours dit savoir que un rôle
privilégié n'ont pas un rôle privilégié
un rôle qui lui revient naturellement
celui d'une des trois grandes
agglomérations sur laquelle la normandie
doit évidemment s'appuyer pour trouver
sa vraie une vraie dynamique et dans ce
rôle d' équilibre au nom d'un des de
l'équipe que j'ai toujours défendues
dans la mesure où la préfecture et à
caen il faut effectivement que le siège
du conseil régional soit à rouen ce qui
ne nous empêchera évidemment pas de
poursuivre les coopération que nous
avons d'ailleurs déjà entamé avec nos
collègues de rouen et du havre
merci joël bonneau d'avoir agi en direct
on va aller à la préfecture de rouen
si vous le voulez bien rejoindre nicolas
v le candidat du front national qui
récolte selon nos estimations pour le
moment 27,4 pour cent des voix qu'on
soit nicolas bay vous êtes en direct sur
france 3 normandie votre réaction par
rapport à l'écart ne serait ce que ça
entre nicolas mayer rossignol et hervé
morin et puis et puis sur votre chiffre
évidemment
écoutez d'abord il est difficile de
commenter les résultats que nous ne
connaissons pas nous ne savons pas qui
finalement va l'emporter ce soir en
normandie
ce qui est sûr saisissant du front
national c'est que nous confortons nos
bons résultats du premier tour le front
national ait été le soir du premier tour
le premier parti de normandie comme il
est d'ailleurs le premier parti de
france et les résultats de ce soir
confirme cette tendance puisque c'est
l'union de plusieurs partis que ce soit
à droite ou à gauche qui permet de
supplanter le front national le front
national qui progresse de façon
spectaculaire par rapport aux élections
de 2010 nous avions à l'époque un peu
plus de 11% des voix et seulement six
élus au conseil régional
là nous atteignons environ 28% des voix
ce qui évidemment est remarquable on
voit aussi que les électeurs normands
ont été plus nombreux à se mobiliser
pour le front national au second tour
puisque nous n'avons pas eu à souffrir
de la hausse de la participation au
contraire et puis je crois aussi que
quelque chose près
nationale j'ai excusez moi j'ai pas
entendu d'autres questions à quelques
voix près vous faites le même score
qu'au premier tour nicolas bay n'y a pas
eu de regret nous savions que sadek
nous savions que ce deuxième tour allait
forcément être difficile puisqu'il y
avait d'abord une focalisation forte
entre hervé morin et nicolas mayer
rossignol et notamment dans des sondages
qui sont parus entre les deux tours et
puis surtout il ya eu il faut pas
l'oublier
une campagne d'entre deux tours
d'hystérie et de violence contre le
front national
porté par le premier ministre porté par
un certain nombre d'autorités morale
autoproclamé on voit bien que les
normands en particulier mais les
français aussi en général ne se sont pas
laissés impressionner ceux qui ont voté
pour le front national qui placent leurs
espoirs dans le front national est bien
ont confirmé leur choix au second tour
donc ça confirme bien que c'est un vrai
vote d'adhésion nous progressons de
façon importante en nombre de voix entre
les deux tours
aujourd'hui le front national est une
force politique absolument
incontournable en normandie
nous avons un tri partys une
tripolarisation de la vie politique
normande qui s'est installée à partir de
ce soir
ce qui change totalement la donne par
rapport à la composition intérieur de
l'hémicycle régional et je crois que ça
montre voilà que le front national
continue de progresser et que la
dynamique est de notre côté
et finalement on le voit d'ailleurs dans
d'autres régions en france ce sont les
combinaisons politiciennes qui empêche
le front national dont il est ici en
normandie où nous n'étions pas donné
gagnant au départ c'était une région où
le front national est un niveau
aujourd'hui élevé mais qui est moins
fort qu'en paca ou en nord pas de calais
picardie et bien malgré tout nous sommes
en capacité voilà de confirmer le
résultat est de nous inscrire dans la
durée comme une force absolument
incontournable merci nicolas bay on vous
retrouvera tout à l'heure sur notre
plateau pour poursuivre cette discussion
et se débat avec les autres têtes de
liste direction le siège de france
télévisions à présent nous partons
retrouver edouard philippe lemaire
républicain du havre bonsoir edouard
philippe
elle vous êtes en direct sur france 3
normandie alors on ne sait pas encore si
vous pourrez vous pourrez boire une
bière avec hervé morin puisque l'écart
est vraiment très très serré on annonce
36 4% selon une estimation pour nicolas
mayer rossignol 36 2% pour hervé morin
maigre écart qui existe entre les deux
ou peut-être une réaction sur sur
l'abstention
on sait qu'au havre elle est très très
importante il semblerait que les
électeurs havrais et plus voter pour ce
second tour ont nettement plus voté il
ya une participation qui a pris près de
8 à 9 points de plus qu'au premier tour
je crois donc il ya eu une mobilisation
au havre comme partout en france
en vérité ce qui est probable ce qui est
probable c'est que l'abstention et est
un peu plus forte au havre qu'ailleurs
parce que traditionnellement au havre il
ya un vote de gauche qui était un peu
plus fort qu'ailleurs et que c'est
surtout l'électorat de gauche en tout
cas au premier tour qui s'est abstenu
voilà mais en tout état de cause c'est
en tout cas ce qui est certain et il
faut s'en réjouir
ce qui est certain il faut s'en réjouir
c'est que les havrais les normands et
les français ont plus voté c'était un
des enjeux de ce scrutin
et c'est une bonne chose quels que
soient les résultats voilà que vous
inspire cette infime écart justement
entre la droite et la gauche
écoutez il montre que on a deux
candidats à la tête de deux équipes qui
ont fait une campagne acharnée acharné
est dans l'ensemble assez respectueuse
et je m'en félicite
il ya d'autres régions de france où les
noms d'oiseaux ont volé à sebha je crois
que ça n'a pas été le cas en normandie
et c'est tant mieux et puis et puis les
normands ont tranché et on est en train
de compter les voix et ça sera serré et
je ne sais pas encore encore dans quel
sens ça tombera mais en tout état de
cause pour l'ensemble de la normandie
demain matin le sujet ça va être
comment est ce qu'on construit un nouvel
ensemble comment est ce qu'on construit
une nouvelle normandie avec elle le
priorité politique
avec quelle façon de travailler entre
nous je voudrais insister sur un point
bien sûr il y aura un gagnant ce soir
bien sûr il y aura des régions ou des
candidats ont gagné mais compte tenu des
résultats du premier tour qui sont
catastrophiques pour tout le monde
compte tenu en tout cas pour ceux qui à
droite ou à gauche refuse
le front national compte tenu de ce que
nous avons appris au premier tour
l'essentiel me semble-t-il désormais
c'est de savoir comment nous allons agir
et comment nous allons essayer grâce à
des nouvelles politiques publiques de
régler les problèmes que jusqu'à présent
nous n'avons pas réussi à régler
et ce défi il sera posée à celui qui
gagnera et aussi à celui qui perd là il
sera posée à tous les territoires de la
normandie c'est un défi considérable et
j'espère que nicolas mas et rossignol ou
hervé morin seront le relever merci est
infinie effectivement c'est une élection
historique puisque c'est la première qui
se déroule sur les cinq départements la
grande normandie va de nouveau être
réunifiée ce qui n'avait pas été le cas
depuis 1956 cette réunification sera
effective le 1er janvier prochain on va
partir à saint lô retrouver jean
baptiste papier quels sont les résultats
est ce qu'ils sont définitifs dans la
bande jean baptiste
ils ne sont toujours pas définitif
franck ici les résultats de 98% des
communes sont arrivés dans cette
préfecture de la manche ici à saint loup
alors en tête la liste droite et centre
conduite par hervé morin avec 40,19 %
des suffrages exprimés
en deuxième position la liste d'union de
la gauche emmenée par nicolas mayer
rossignol avec 34,82 % des suffrages
exprimés et en troisième position le
front national nicolas bay 25,20 % des
suffrages les villes qui ont voté à
droite
mortain 40 ans villedieu les poêles
avranches valognes granville sainte
hilaire du harcouët à gauche pour le
moment seul saint lô où nous avons
installé notre caméra a voté largement à
gauche
il manque une ville et pas des moindres
cherbourg le fief du ministre de
l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve le résultat n'est
toujours pas arrivé rappelons qu'ici
dans la manche il y a dix sept sièges à
pourvoir dans la future assemblée de la
région normandie merci jean baptiste
pour ces informations depuis la
préfecture à saint lô on retrouvera
certainement cours de la soirée les
résultats continuent de nous parvenir un
résultat à flers dans l'orne justement
43,87 c'est la liste dit
nicolas mayer rossignol la liste d'union
de la gauche qui arrive en tête dans
l'orne devant celle d'hervé morin devant
cette ville dans cette ville de l'orne
et 32 88 pour hervé morin et 23 25 pour
nicolas bay dans cette ville de flers on
va retrouver justement le maire
d'alençon
on va dans l'orne joaquim pueyo bonsoir
le suspense en soirée et entier ce soit
on ne sait pas si la gauche ou si la
droite va remporter ces élections
régionales quel est votre sentiment vous
y croyez vous à cette victoire justement
dans votre camp oui je j'ai toujours
pensé cette victoire mais il faut rester
serein parce qu'on n'a pas encore les
résultats définitifs
je vois que alençon les électeurs se
sont mobilisés autour de la liste
dirigée par nicolas mayer rossignol et
laurent bouvet put 44% 44 37
donc le report c'est bien fait la
mobilisation ça a été également établi
et jeu quand je regarde les communes de
la commune et urban et la première
couronne les listes menées par nicolas
mayer annuels sont également en tête je
pense à des villes comme
saint-germain-du-corbéis d'amis ni qu'on
dit sur sarthe n'aurait pour citer ceux
dont j'ai connaissance des résultats
donc la ville d'alençon et la commune et
urbaines ont porté en tête nicolas mayer
rossignol c'est une reconnaissance du
travail qui a été fait entre la région
et la communauté urbaine d'alençon bon
bilan bon projet et je pense que les
électeurs ont été sensibles également au
travail que nous menons sur les
territoires bien sûr j'attends avec
beaucoup de série d'idées le résultat
final jose bien sûr espérer et j'espère
comme tous ceux qui ont soutenu nicolas
mayer rossignol le une victoire ce qui
certes au finish
mais si c'est au finish toute façon elle
sera mérité merci joaquim pueyo d'avoir
réagi et en direct depuis la préfecture
d'alençon dans l'orne avec nous sur ce
plateau nous a rejoints céline brulin
pour le front de gauche je posais la
question justement il ya quelques
minutes à yannick soubien d'europe
écologie les verts
vous avez fait la fusion de l'uo de la
gauche mais ça se joue à très peu ce
soir alors que le rapport de force était
nettement à votre avantage même question
elle souhaite être surpris par eux
c'est tendance parce que on ne parle que
d'estimations pour l'instant mais les
estimations dont on dispose à cette
heure montre que les reports de voix à
gauche se sont plutôt bien fait sur une
liste qui s'est en effet rassemblé mais
que le surcroît de participation entre
les deux tours a visiblement bénéficié à
la droite puisqu'elle enregistre des
scores nettement supérieure et qu'on
observe également qu' une partie de
l'électorat fn qui se reportait sur la
droite mais comme vous dites attendons
les résultats définitifs jean jacques
thorel qui était tête de liste du front
national justement dans le département
de la manche n'était pas d'accord avec
vous justement sur le report des voix
par des voies non je pense moi je pense
pas qu'ils aient des électeurs du front
national qui soit reportée sur le sur le
vote deux sur la liste de monsieur morin
je voudrais d'abord moi remercier tous
les électeurs qui ont fait confiance au
front national
les centaines de milliers d'électeurs
qui nous ont apporté leur soutien c'est
important de les remercier ce soir
puisque ils ont été victimes comme nous
d'une campagne hystérique entre les deux
tours contre le front national en
environ une droite ou un les médias les
artistes et voilà et je voudrais
remercier ce soir remercie aussi tous
les militants qui ont fait un travail
exceptionnel depuis des mois au sein de
toute la normandie
vous avez siéger à la région ce avec une
première pour vous devant lequel quel
genre des lustres et vous jeu actuel je
pense que je serai intransigeant sur une
opposition intransigeante mettront sous
mais constructive
voilà nous nous marquerons quel que soit
le l'équipe qui arrivera en tête ce soir
il faut qu'elle sache qu'elle sera
marqué à la culotte et qu'elle n'aura
pas le droit à l'erreur
est-ce que vous progressez en nombre des
sièges là forcément les dix multiplie
par trois et demi notre notre score de
2010 nous aurons un groupe d'élus
important à la région
nous attendons un marathon on aura
atteint un niveau du jamais vu dans
l'histoire du front national en
normandie autour du thème des lucéens
peut-être oui on va voir on va en faudra
affiner avec les derniers résultats qui
vont tomber sur ce sursaut doit se jouer
à quelques dixièmes voilà ça s'est vu
sur 102 un groupe qu'on n'aura jamais eu
depuis depuis le début du front national
en normandie qui votre adversaire
justement est l'ennemi numéro un
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est la droite
traditionnelle
ou est ce que c'est le front national
regard des scores certes de ce seront
toujours mais aussi du premier tour on a
vu poussée du fn
je suis toujours gêné enfin ne pas
parler de l'adversaire je crois que
c'est un point peu fort je sais qu'on a
une grande responsabilité
bien sûr toujours et puis après on
travaille voilà mais effectivement je
crois que nous avons de grandes
responsabilités ce scrutin montre on a
vu il ya une forte mobilisation et une
responsabilité de tourner plus
importante qu effectivement il y a eu
cette mobilisation au deuxième tour ça
veut dire que les électeurs nous dise
quelque chose et et cela veut dire que
il faut il faudra analyser tout cela
s'est compliqué ce soir d'autant plus
que nous n'avons pas tous les résultats
vous avez parlé des questions de reports
de voix effectivement il faut aussi
regarder ça très finement et les uns les
autres nous allons quel que soit le
résultat
regardez ce que vous voulez ce que les
électeurs ont voulu nous dire et en
responsabilité commencé à travailler que
nous soyons dans la majorité ou
opposition au vu de tout cela
vous êtes d'accord avec madame mialon
burgat madame catherine morin desailly
faut beaucoup d'humilité face à ces
résultats en tout cas face aux
estimations qu'on a en tout cas qu'on
sait de toute façon que les résultats
sont serrés bien entendu je crois que
l'analyse d'edouard philippe était
extrêmement justes tout à l'heure nous
avons un coup de semonce très important
lors de ce premier tour des élections
dans la france entière
donc ça fait beaucoup de modestie qu'il
faut aborder ces résultats et puis
réaliser que c'est une crise de
confiance profonde qui s'est exprimée de
la part de
des français il faut en tenir compte je
pense que c'était avec une nouvelle
responsabilité qu'il faut aborder ce
mandat régional revoir aussi la manière
de travail et les politiques publiques
en tout état de cause on ne peut pas
occulter ce qui s'est passé au premier
tour ces résultats qui instaure une
forte de tripartisme en france avec les
extrêmes extrêmement puissant ça renvoie
ça renvoie à des questions que nous
devons nous poser d'avon un devoir de
nous poser des questions pour répondre
aux préoccupations des français qui sont
très inquiet par rapport à l'avenir et
une crise de confiance les profondes
autant à moins de deux ans de la
présidentielle je voudrais juste donné
un résultat à cette fois sur la ville de
rouen avec nicolas mayer rossignol qui
arrive en tête devant hervé morin et
nicolas veille c'était déjà le cas lors
du premier tour mais un autre résultat
qui vient de parvenir sur lisieux dans
le calvados c'est la liste d'hervé morin
qui arrive en tête avec 42 29% des voix
devant celle de nicolas mayer rossignol
32,74 et le front national à 26,97 on va
retrouver en duplex de caen à la
préfecture du calvados eu quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup oeuvré pour la réunification
de la normandie c'est le député prg du
calvados alain tourret bonsoir merci
d'être en direct sur france 3 normandie
on voit que c'est extrêmement serré 36,4
% selon la dernière estimation pour le
candidat de la gauche 36,2 % pour hervé
morin ces chiffres sont en train de
s'affiner
quelle est votre réaction ce soir vous
qui avez tant que vrai pour que ont
construit cette grande normandie vient
tout d'abord de participer à un moment
historique pour la première fois on va
désigner les élus de toute la normandie
rien qu'en normandie et moi qui suis
depuis toujours le militants de la
réunification je suis particulièrement
heureux surtout que se dessine la
victoire du candidat de la gauche
cette famille à laquelle j'appartiens et
je pense que nicolas mayer rossignol
soir
le premier des présidents de la
normandie réunifiée est ce que votre
coeur ne balance pas un peu à la torre
lorsqu'on sait que vous avez co présidé
l'association pour la réunification de
la normandie avec votre ami hervé morin
même si vous souteniez nicolas mayer
rossignol
on sait l'affection vous avez quelque
part pour le candidat de la droite
vous n'êtes pas un peu partagé ce soir
la politique par moments elle a des
chemins qui sont durs
ma famille politique c'est celle de
nicolas mayer rossignol cela ne veut pas
dire que je retire toute mon amitié à
hervé morin bien évidemment mais ce soir
ce qui me semble surtout important c'est
de dire que le front national nulle part
en france deux gagnants
le front national est dans les choux et
l'attitude intransigeante de manuel
valls vis-à-vis du front national à
payer et c'est ce qui me semble plus
important car à la prochaine élection
présidentielle celui qui gagnera sera
celui qui s'opposera au front national
or avec la politique du ni ni le
président nicolas sarkozy a
manifestement déserté son devoir
d'obligations et d'opposition vision du
front national à tours et simplement
rapidement vous êtes l'auteur d'un
amendement qui prévoit un équilibre
entre caen et rouen
c'est ce fameux débat sur la capitale la
place de chacun justement l'équilibré
entre ces deux villes
que dites-vous très clairement en deux
mots ce soir comment on répartit cet
équipement ans entre les deux villes
l'équilibré il est accepté et acté la
préfecture de région et aaron le conseil
régional et à caen et le conseil
régional sera à caen avec l'ensemble de
ses services et c'est là que se
tiendront les principales réunions du
conseil régional d'un côté
l'administratif de l'autre côté le
politique c'est ce partage que j'ai
voulu c'est ce partage qui a été acté
par les uns et par les autres et je m'en
félicite
merci à nador et d'avoir répondu en
direct sur notre antenne depuis la
préfecture du calvados on va partir pour
la préfecture d'evreux dans l'eure
retrouver frédéric nicolas qui a des
résultats définitifs pour le département
dites nous donc frédéric on en a déjà
donné des résultats mais est ce que
c'était les mêmes que les vôtres à
l'heure dite nous non voilà cette fois
ci on a ceux qui sont du sceau de la
préfecture d'evreux donc ces résultats
sont les suivants 36 31% pour hervé
morin dont qui menait la liste d'union
de la droite qui arrive donc en tête
trois points devant celle du front
national menée par nicolas bézy de
timothée houssin dans le département de
l'eure 33 33%
puis nicolas mayer rossignol en
troisième position 30,36 % donc voyez
les trois listes qui sont séparés par
trois points donc les résultats étaient
très serrés je vous donne des résultats
d'autres illustrations dans des villes
par exemple à evreux dans la ville de
guy lefrand c'est nicolas mayer
rossignol qui l'emportait avec 39 points
0 5% devant hervé morin 38,17 % seuls
sans voix séparaient les deux candidats
à louviers là aussi c'était très serré
mal avantage de monsieur morin sur
monsieur mayer rossignol et puis à
gisors un score important pour le front
national signé yoan long le 37 50 % le
front national qui améliore son score
par rapport au premier tour
merci beaucoup nicolas monsieur meyer et
signale en tête dans la ville d'evreux
monsieur le franc dans votre ville oui
ça se joue à 100 voix donc effectivement
c'est très limité mais heureux comme le
havre est une ville qui était
historiquement sociologiquement de
gauche et par rapport au report des voix
qui aurait dû se faire
nous faisons plus que résister mais moi
ce qui m'interpelle ce soir ce sont les
résultats du front national aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il a plus suffire de dire
oui on vous a entendu on entendu votre
colère alors maintenant il faut
s'interroger réellement sur le sentiment
d'acculturation de certains sur le
sentiment d'abandon notamment des zones
rurales sur le sentiment d' exagération
de la pression fiscale et de la pression
sociale
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il s'agit plus
simplement d'être condescendant ou
d'avoir de la compassion
il faut maintenant apporter de vraies
réponses ça aujourd'hui là qu'il faut
dire ce soir c'est du moins l'ambition
aussi que le message que vous portez
renforce le front national moi je crois
très clairement quand je vois les
résultats du front national dans leur
que le jeu que joue la droite dans ce
département fait progresser le front
national alors ça n'est pas le seul
aspect parce qu'il ya aussi on le verra
avec confirmation des résultats mais
visiblement une participation plus
importante de l'électorat de droite et
pas ce sursaut à gauche ce qui témoigne
aussi d'un mécontentement à gauche qu'il
faut entendre
nous n'avons cessé de le dire pendant
toute cette campagne est une colère il
faut l'entendre et il faut reconstruire
l'espoir et reconstruire la gauche mais
je pense que la droite joue un jeu très
dangereux avec le front national voilà
et on dirait qu'on nous apporte les
résultats
vif dans le département de l'orne où
c'est hervé morin qui arrive en tête
avec 37% des suffrages devant nicolas
mayer rossignol 33 23 et le front
national et nicolas b 56 là aussi c'est
relativement serré il y à sept points
d'écart entre la liste de la droite et
celle du front national
on va rejoindre en duplex de la
préfecture de saint lô david margueritte
qui menait la liste de l'union de la
droite et du centre dans le département
de la manche bonsoir monsieur marguerite
bonsoir selon les dernières informations
ça serait extrêmement serré et le
suspense ne serait pas levé 1 / sur la
normandie ça se jouerait à quelques
dizaines quelques centaines de voix près
un jeu rappelle que le dernier chiffre
que l'on à communiquer c'est celui de
l'estimation ipsos 36,4 pour nicolas mas
et rossignol 36,2 pour la rue morin et
30 et 27 points 4 pour nicolas bay
est-ce que selon vous la victoire la
reconquête ou la conquête même de la
normandie puisque elle sera réunifiée
1er janvier est possible à l'instant où
nous parlons oui je le crois parce que
vous indiquez le sondage en tout cas
l'estimation de d'ipsos d'autres
instituts donnent des estimations
contraire à leur nom là alors il me
semble que nous avons une légère avance
dans d'autres instituts la seule chose
qui est certaine à l'heure où nous
parlons c'est que nous avons remporté
déjà des départements c'est le cas dans
la manche puisque nous obtenons un bon
résultat à priori qui est partielle
encore mais la liste de la normandie et
conquérante qui était conduite par hervé
morin devrait dépasser ou avoisiner les
40 % avec un écart de cinq points sur la
liste de gauche ce qui est pour nous
déjà un succès maintenant évidemment
nous ne savons pas ce qu'il en est sur
l'ensemble de la normandie
la soirée pourrait en effet être longue
mais ce qui est certain c'est que la
semaine dernière on nous a annoncé que
compte tenu des reports de voix nous
n'étions plus favori dans cette élection
nous voyons ce soir que de nombreux
électeurs se sont mobilisés pour dire
leur volonté d'alternance
dire aussi que nous étions la seule
alternance crédible et je voudrais les
en remercier vous siégeraient quoi qu'il
arrive à la région puisque vous étiez
peut-être de liste dans ce département
de la manche
excusez moi c'est une question un peu
personnel la vie de marguerite vous
aviez été candidats sur cherbourg aux
municipales candidats au départemental
c'est votre victoire personnelle quelque
part ce soir aussi alors je pourrais
parler de victoire si nous l'emportons
vraiment sur l'ensemble de la région
mais en effet les scores que nous
réalisons sur le département de la
manche sont une grande satisfaction
personnelle mais bien sûr aussi pour
celles et ceux qui m'ont soutenu qui ont
soutenu la liste de la normandie
conquérante les parlementaires nous
avions mené un grand rassemblement je
crois une campagne de proximité
une campagne qui a été dynamique et qui
paye aujourd'hui dans les urnes et c'est
vrai que je m'en réjouis
c'est un enseignement aussi c'est que
dans la vie politique comme dans la vie
tout court il faut se battre être
déterminée tenace et poursuivre ses
objectifs et j'espère ce soir que nous
aurons la possibilité d'agir dans la
majorité
merci david margueritte alors on l'a dit
un franck pendant des semaines et
pendant le premier tour le débat le
débat du second tour c'est une élection
historique mais historique on l'aurait
jamais imaginé à ce point là puisque
l'écart n'a jamais été aussi infimes
entre le premier et le deuxième au
second tour vous disiez tout à l'heure
madame brûlant qu'il fallait mobiliser
mais j'ai l'impression que ça fait des
années qu'on entend ça c'est clair quand
on voit que l'abstention même si là il
ya une plus forte participation et on
peut s'en féliciter entre les deux tours
mais globalement il ya une abstention
structurel c'est à dire qu'il ya un vrai
fossé entre les gens qui dirigent le
pays et qui commence y compris à gagner
d'autres fins des élus parfois locaux et
donc je pense que pour reconquérir la
confiance de nos concitoyens
il faut d'abord les écouter entendre
leur colère à gauche comme à droite et
puis il faut il faut mener des
politiques qui changent concrètement et
directement leur vie le chômage continue
de progresser la désindustrialisation
continue de faire son effet le lait
les la désertification médicale
s'amplifie une seconde simplement un
volant puisqu'il ya un chiffre qui vient
de nous parvenir à l'instant qui est un
chiffre du ministère de l'intérieur sur
89 % des bureaux dépouillés en normandie
ça peut encore bouger mais ce chiffre
fait état d'une avance d'hervé morin le
candidat de la droite avec 37 0 5%
devant le candidat de l'union de la
gauche nicolas mayer rossignol avec
34,72 89% pour dépouiller mais une
avance de trois points presque néant
quoi philippe muser justement vous allez
là chaque fois qu'il ya ce jour le
problème
il est important de savoir à quoi
correspond justement le score qu'on nous
annonce et surtout qu'est-ce qui reste à
consulter parce que vous doutez bien que
selon les secteurs ça peut changer
énormément de choses surtout quand les
vices qui sont en tête sont vraiment
très proches les unes des autres 28,20
3% donc à une certaine progression tout
de même on va peut-être aller voir
aurélie à misery qui scrute pour nous le
web durant toute cette soirée électorale
aurélie qu avez-vous noté de votre côté
du côté des tweetos vous avez forcément
des commentaires mais goûter emilie je
peux vous dire que sur les réseaux
sociaux on partage ce moment historique
regarder ce commentaire très clairement
la soirée électorale la plus excitante
depuis longtemps alors les internautes
scrute effectivement les résultats à
l'image des politiques cette photo a été
prise par nos journalistes à la
fédération du parti socialiste de rebond
peu avant 8 heures les internautes
vivent avec nous ce suspense ils ont
bien compris que si tu es très serré
regarder cette sélection de commentaire
normandie match nul à cet instant autre
commentaire thriller en normandie
forcément fidèles à notre tradition
régionale normandie film fidèle à elle
même peut-être ben qu'oui peut-être
maintenant
gauche ou droite point d'interrogation
un commentaire qui revient très souvent
alors on a parlé de la participation en
forte hausse
devant ce match gauche
droite très serré cet internaute
regrette simplement de s'être abstenus
vous pouvez suivre toutes nos
informations et nos résultats sur notre
site internet avec notre live minute par
minute
animé par nos équipes web de caen merci
aidant - merci beaucoup aurélie ce
dernier chiffre
97 % de bureaux dépouillés en normandie
et hervé morin qui totaliserait 36 5%
des voix nicolas mayer rossignol 35,6 il
ya un point des coeurs il ya trois
points sont encore en jeu revient de
route à leur 21h15 pour revenir bien sûr
sur ses études estimations et sur des
résultats définitifs on l'espère à tout
à l'heure sur france 3